well pliability nutrition hydration
movement and mental Fitness these are
the five pillars of the tb12 method
helping you be a goat in your own Game
of Life here's Rocky to explain
there is a new way to win at The Encore
and it's all about the tv-12 method so
we are here Turf is laid out they've
only been open for about two weeks to
the public coach Rob tell us what we're
doing here so this is again like you
mentioned this is the TV 12 method so
it's all based on Tom Brady again like
one of the greatest players of all time
right the goat one of the goats Alex
Guerrero and what they've done together
to kind of prolong his career okay and
what our goal is here obviously
everybody doesn't have to be Tom Brady
right the Peak Performance and
pliability they're kind of our words
Peak Performance we want to bring that
to you bring that to the general public
whether it's playing in the NFL on
Sundays or playing with your kids at
home we want you to be able to do that
and live pain-free yeah strength and
endurance longevity so we have some we
have some of your coaches right here
what are they doing tell us some of the
so we're kind of demonstrating here what
you normally get is you'll get a
one-on-one session right so you would
come in and we would work together and
address whatever your issues are to help
you achieve your performance my knees
right and with knees and back a lot of
that all comes back to hips and glutes
absolutely what they're kind of
demonstrating here is this is a glute
strengthening exercise okay which is
going to help to build that firm
foundation and she's doing some
self-pliability over here on the roller
and we have a vibrating roller that is
it doesn't feel so great right but it's
your best friend because it's gonna get
those muscles long and loose and pliable
and help you to sustain the changes that
you're making with the exercises and
appliability so how long does someone
start to see results with the TV 12
method within the first session you're
seeing results I love that it's in the
first session every time okay now why
the wind partnership why bring tb12 to
the Encore so Tom Brady has a history I
mean the match the golf course that's
right that was all here for the for the
big event right so they have a long
storied history and they've kind of
going back and forth and
so here we are here we are how do people
come in here and and use your services
how do they make an appointment with you
so absolutely so there's a couple
different ways you can go on
tb12sports.com and you can go through
there you can call the spa The Encore
spa and you can also go on
winlasvegas.com we're on there as well
and that'll help us to get help you get
in get your schedule let's do it train
like Tom Brady here at the Encore TV 12
method welcome to Vegas
and coming up we're going to focus on
recovery right because that is just as
equally as important as the strength
training
thank you Rocky we will share part two
of that interview later on in the week